imagine you were asked to describe the
perfect candidate for president
what qualities would you pick maybe
you'd want them to be a scientist
someone who
bases policy on evidence maybe you'd
want them to be a great humanitarian or
a business leader or to understand the
lives
of ordinary folk if that's the case then
all we have to say to you is be careful
what you wish for
in 1928 americans really did elect a man
with all those great qualities
and many more his name was herbert
hoover and he was one of the worst
presidents in u.s history
prior to 1928 the idea of a hoover
presidency would have seemed
a utopia as a self-made businessman
hoover had saved millions of lives in
world war one
through famine relief later he helped
america through one of its worst ever
natural disasters
had he died then he would still be
remembered as a great humanitarian
instead
his name is forever to be linked to the
great depression a crisis
that he fought to overcome only to be
consumed by it
today we're examining the life of the
31st president a remarkable man
who became a dismal leader
if you were a producer looking for a
good rags to riches story to turn into
an inspiring movie
you couldn't get much better than the
life of herbert born into a hard-working
quaker family in iowa on august 10 1874
hoover had a tragic childhood enough to
make even the most hardened movie go a
weep
when he was just six his blacksmith
father died of a heart attack just ten
days before christmas
barely three years later in 1884 his
mother was killed by typhoid fever
aged only nine hoover became an orphan
to call this a formative moment in the
boy's life
would be to redefine the meaning of
understatement the death of hoover's
parents devastated the boy for the rest
of his life it'd be both shy and
suspicious of others while also filled
with
a powerful drive to succeed to never
again experience the poverty
and misery of his orphan years you could
see evidence of this drive at his
studies eventually settling with an
uncle in oregon hoover spent most of his
school years as a crappy student
then in the late 1880s he suddenly got
it into his head that he was going to
study at the new
elite college opening in california this
was the shiny new campus that everyone
had taken to calling
the cornell of the west to those who
didn't know him well this must have
seemed like a mad dream
he was a bad student from an
impoverished background not the type for
a place like stanford but for those who
knew his drive
knew the dark demons propelling him on
they might have guessed what would
happen next
that hoover would work his ass off
sticking to a punishing revision
schedule that he'd somehow scrape into
stanford
joining its first ever class that he'd
take two part-time jobs and start a
student laundry service to pay for his
geology degree that did study
harder than any of the richer kids there
alongside him with maybe one exception
lou henry was a one-woman powerhouse of
intelligence athleticism and all-round
badassery stanford's first female
geology student she was every bit as
driven as hoover you won't be surprised
to hear that the young man soon decided
to marry her but first
he needed to make some money after
graduating in 1895 who took back
breaking jobs working
70 hours a week hauling ore at gold
mines until he could
land something more fitting it took
months but at last he made contact with
the company in need of someone to travel
the world and examine mines for them to
buy
it was the beginning of two decades of
adventure sent to australia in 1897
hoover quickly picked up a new contract
in china
where it'd be a consultant for the
emperor himself before he left hoover
cabled lou henry asking if she'd marry
him we can only assume that henry's
answer was the 19th century equivalent
of
yeah herbertova and lou henry
married in california on february the
10th 1899.
their honeymoon was to jump aboard a
boat to china to start hoover's new job
and their new lives in the far east at
first it'd be a great
experience the two would even learn
mandarin something they'd use whenever
they wanted a private conversation for
the rest of their lives but it would
also be an experience that came close
to ending those same lives china in 1899
was on the verge of another of its
periodic cataclysms this one an uprising
that would
specifically target foreigners known as
the boxer rebellion it would kill a
hundred thousand people in a matter of
weeks
it would also be the making of herbert
[Music]
hoover
from the safety of the 21st century the
boxer rebellion could almost seem
funny in its sheer insanity led by the
society of the righteous and harmonious
fists its soldiers believed they were so
ripped that they could deflect bullets
but there was nothing
vaguely amusing about being on the
receiving end of it
in june 1900 the boxes attacked major
cities slaughtering and besieging
foreigners and chinese christians for
hoover and lou
caught in modern tianjin it was like
being in the middle of a full-scale war
hoover was forced to build barricades to
protect their small
expat district marshaling the 800 other
foreigners to help with defense lu
meanwhile volunteered to nurse the
wounded
it took until august for a coalition of
imperial powers to fight its way into
china and liberate the besieged cities
tens of thousands of people died yet it
wasn't
fear hoover felt during the rebellion
although there was plenty of that
it was responsibility a dawning
realization that he was a good leader in
a crisis someone who could take
charge and get things done while that
ability helped save a few hundred lives
in the box rebellion
it would soon be used to save millions
so okay it's time for our story to take
a big
leap through time all the way to 1914.
in the near decade and a half we've
skipped over hoover opened his own
mining business becoming a self-made
millionaire he also found himself a
political home identifying with the
progressive wing of the republican party
his literal home
however was thousands miles away in
london where he lived the charmed life
of a
wealthy happy family man had he never
done anything again he could have still
died knowing
that he'd won the game of life in
reality though hoover's life
barely even started it would take one of
the greatest cataclysms of the 20th
century to finally kick things into gear
the outbreak of world war 1 was a domino
effect that saw europe go from being
fine if tense to screaming quagmire of
death within
just a few weeks some 120 000 american
expats and tourists were forced to flee
britain where they discovered that
not only were all the boats to the u.s
cancelled but they could no longer get
money on credit
it was an american refugee crisis one
which could have overwhelmed london
had it not been for herbert hoover along
with a few wealthy friends hoover set up
and coordinated a relief earth at the
trapped americans not only providing
them with shelter
but also organizing their evacuation it
was such an impressive logistical feat
that it brought him to the u.s
ambassador's attention but when hoover
was called to meet walter hines paige
it wasn't to be congratulated no paige
wanted hoover to set up an even bigger
relief program
by fall 1914 belgium was on the brink of
starvation
overrun by a brutal german invasion
blockaded by the british navy the
country's 9 million people
were in danger of slipping into famine
paige asked hoover if he could do
anything to help to do for the belgians
what he'd done for the americans trapped
in london hoover picked up that request
and ran a god damn marathon with it
as head of the commission for relief in
belgium or crb
hoover took charge of a relief effort
unparalleled in history some 40
000 volunteers in belgium had to be
coordinated to effectively distribute
food to remote villages
while the crb simultaneously had to
maintain a massive international network
for sourcing donations
on top of that who had to negotiate with
the british navy to let his food
shipments through the blockade and with
the german military to make sure that
they didn't confiscate the supplies
today we take for granted the existence
of charities that do similar stuff on a
regular basis but until the crb set to
work no one had done anything
on a scale like this at its height the
crb was feeding approximately 11 million
people over an area of 20
000 square miles it was a barnstorming
feat of logistics an effort that saved
untold millions in belgium from
starvation incredibly though
herbert hoover was just getting started
over in america hoover's humanitarian
work hadn't gone unnoticed
although there was some talk
unbelievably of prosecuting him for
violating neutrality laws
many powerful people were taking note of
the businessman's achievements
among their number was president woodrow
wilson although hoover was a republican
wilson knew a good man for a job when he
saw one and as the u.s ended world war
one in 1917
wilson had the perfect job for hoover to
help the u.s
feed its european allies by this stage
of the war britain france and italy were
relying on u.s
exports to keep them from starvation
unfortunately this was pushing up the
price of staples back home leading
americans to riot at
the thought of going hungry just so some
random french dude could
keep nibbling croissants it was uber's
job to sell these shortages to the
public
he did better than president wilson
could have dreamed under hoover the food
administration pushed the idea that
frugal living
was patriotic meatless mondays and
weeklies wednesdays became a callback to
a time of simpler lives of the graft and
sacrifice that had made america great
so successful was the program that
hoover's name became a common verb
to hooverize meant to avoid waste by the
time the war ended in november 1918
hoover was seen by the public as a hero
and by wilson as an organizational
genius and that was no bad thing
because with the war over europe was in
desperate need of organization
empires had collapsed new countries had
been born
wars erupted and economies bottomed out
it was a continent in desperate need of
food
clothing medicine anything that might
make a difference for woodrow wilson
the man to meet those needs was herbert
hoover in february 1919 congress
authorized the creation
of the american relief administration or
ara
hoover was given millions of dollars and
told to go and save lives and
that's exactly what he did we can't
cover all 20 nations the ara worked in
without turning this video into
one long gratuitous kiss but
here are a couple of highlights in
poland then fighting a war with russia
hoover's ara was estimated to feed half
a million children each day
leading to the claim that for the poles
the name woodrow wilson spelled freedom
while the name herbert hoover spelled
life over on the other side of the
battle lines the ara also organized
enough soup kitchens to feed 11 million
russians a day
when critics complained that he was
propping up communism hoover famously
replied
20 million people are starving whatever
their politics they shall be
fed so admirable was this attitude that
upon hearing of the great humanitarian's
work future rival franklin d roosevelt
remarked
he is certainly a wonder and i wish we
could make him president of the united
states
there could not be a better one but a
1920 hoover presidential run was not to
be instead the republican nominee that
year would be businessman
warren g harding a guy so corrupt his
presidency today ranks alongside those
of andrew johnson and james buchanan for
non-americans confused by that reference
just imagine a gigantic turd sat next to
two other gigantic turds the slightly
smaller turd with the stupid eyebrows
well that's warren harding despite his
overall turdiness harding did do one
smart thing
in his only turn well technically two
smart things but the second one
was more of a fluke the first was making
hoover his secretary of commerce by now
hoover's name was synonymous with
bounding energy and efficiency
in his new post the great humanitarian
pushed hard on cutting-edge tech like
aviation standardized hardware across
industries and signed off on colossal
projects like the hoover dam the second
smart thing that harding did
well i was dying in june 1923 harding
hinted to hoover that his administration
might be covering up some sort of
scandal before it could be exposed
though
harding died of a heart attack and was
replaced by calvin coolidge
that meant coolidge could dump all of
the blame on the dead harding when the
teapot dome scandal finally erupted
allowing the gop to survive what would
have otherwise been a brutal 1924
election
that's how come the late 1920s herbert
hoover found himself in a high-profile
government position
with massive public support under a boss
who didn't want another term
in other words he was perfectly placed
to run for president
but it would take more than just name
recognition for hoover to sew up the
1928 nomination
first he'd have to handle one of the
greatest natural disasters
in u.s history
[Music]
in april 1927 months of rainfall finally
overwhelmed the mississippi river's
flood defenses
one by one levees failed across multiple
states a domino effect of destruction
that sent water rolling across farmland
annihilating everything in its path an
area the size of west virginia was
simply washed away with at least
500 people killed hundreds of thousands
made homeless and over three quarters of
a million left without access to food it
was the biggest natural disaster of its
era one which demanded
an immediate response it was also
hoover's chance to shine
although he was a humanitarian by nature
hoover was not an idiot he knew that
organizing successful disaster relief in
spring 1927
might well win him the presidency so he
set to it with manic intensity charting
boats to rescue the stranded building
displaced persons camps and
distributing supplies to everyone who
needed them well
almost everyone ignored by the white
majority at the time who proclaimed
hoover a hero a scandal erupted when it
was revealed that hoover's men were
diverting supplies away from black
refugees and
sometimes just leaving them stranded the
outrage was so great it's been said the
mississippi floods represent the moment
black voters began to question their
allegiance to the gop
setting the stage for their historic
shift toward the democrats
in 1927 though the mainstream narrative
was that hoover was a genius
someone who could marshal his skills to
overcome any disaster so when he
announced that he was going to run for
president
the outcome seemed like a no-brainer in
summer 1928 the great humanitarian was
handed his party's nomination the vp on
the tickets was charles curtis the first
person with
native american ancestry to reach such
high office together the two declared
that they'd continue the prosperity
of the coolidge years given hoover's
popularity he could have probably spent
the campaign asleep
on his sofa and still won but he threw
himself into the task famously promising
a chicken in every pot and a car in
every garage
for their part the democrats put up a
sacrificial lamb new york governor
alfred
smith man described by one hoover
supporting preacher as the candidate of
card playing cocktail drinking poodle
dogs divorcees
novels stuffy rooms dancing evolution
clarence dao
nude art prize fighting actors greyhound
racing and modernism
a little note to self here start
describing my enemies that way
when november finally rolled around
there were no surprises
hoover crushed it at the polls taking 58
of the vote
and all but eight states for an
electoral college landslide at his
inauguration on march the 4th 1929 he
proclaimed that
in no nation are the fruits of
accomplishment more secure
anyone not only can be rich but ought to
be rich
but of course the economic storm clouds
were already gathering all through the
back half of the 1920s the stock market
had soared divorcing itself from reality
in ways that wouldn't be seen again
until 2007.
in other sections of the economy chill
winds were beginning to blow
the results of structural problems
ignored far too long by
far too many people little did those
watching the hoover inauguration on
sound reels across the nation know it
but the jazz age the era of prosperity
art deco flappers and gatsby
was about to come crashing to an end in
its place would come an era of
uncertainty
unemployment creeping fascism and quiet
despair
had hoover known the cataclysm that
awaited is just possible he might have
wished alfred smith had won after all
[Music]
no matter who was in charge when the
great depression hit it would have ended
their presidency over the coming years
unemployment would leap from barely
three percent to nearly a quarter of the
workforce gdp would
crater dropping 30 by the end of
hoover's term thousands of banks would
have collapsed 20
of all farms closed and the nation would
be hemorrhaging a hundred thousand jobs
a week
those numbers are so bad that only
parallel is the absolute peak of the
2020 coveted crisis and
even then things eased off in a matter
of months rather than staying that way
for years so yeah any averagely
competent president
would have been absolutely screwed sadly
hoover wasn't even average there were
warning signs in the handful of
pre-crash moments that hoover's genius
at disaster relief
hadn't translated very well to the
presidency he seemed unable to work with
congress he
floundered over a couple of important
bills failed to communicate with
a public that still adored him had
hoover become president during a boom he
might have been able to coast
to go down as an okay-ish leader the
sort of inoffensive president everyone
struggles to remember when doing quizzes
but then came october 1929
and hoover's fate was sealed although
the wall street crash is today heralded
as the clearest start point for the
great depression
at the time it was just considered
another slump hoover's advisors
basically
shrugged and told him there was nothing
he could do but
for all his faults the 31st president
wasn't content
to simply stand by and wait that
november hoover convened conferences
between big businesses and organized
labor and
won important agreements to avoid
layoffs and strikes
separately he leaned on states to
authorize new public works projects to
boost employment he even cut taxes to
stimulate spending ever since he left
office people have liked to portray
hoover as an american nero someone who
fiddled while the country burned
but that's simply not true no the real
tragedy of hoover's presidency
is that he tried his best to tackle the
crisis but a combination of his
political beliefs and a failure to grasp
the depression's magnitude
and he was forever 20 steps behind
events that december despite hoover's
efforts one million americans lost their
jobs in the week before christmas
from there on things would only get
worse as 1930 got underway the president
launched initiative after failed
initiative to try and help the economy
he pushed through a tariff act intended
to give struggling farmers a captive
market
only for the act to kneecap american
imports and exports and hurt the wider
economy he set up an emergency committee
to coordinate unemployment relief but
refused to authorize direct payments or
welfare he pleaded with the states to
fund more infrastructure to generate
jobs but
backed off from forcing through federal
bills that would guarantee the same
meanwhile the breadlines just kept
getting longer by the end of the year
with unemployment closing in on 10
parts of congress began begging hoover
to get the government involved
to bring in a doll or experiment with
direct relief but hoover refused
as a man who'd pulled himself out of an
impoverished childhood via his own grit
and hard work
he simply couldn't see why others
couldn't do the same
at his core hoover believed that america
was a great nation filled with kindly
individuals
people who would help their fellow man
without the need for government
intervention
but that america was dead it was killed
by the crash
in its place was a land ravaged by
hunger by despair by people desperate
for help
they couldn't get any from the great
humanitarian by 1931 vast shanty towns
were cropping up on the outskirts of
cities as the newly destitute were
evicted from their homes the public soon
settled on a name for these makeshift
encampments
one which summed up their feelings
towards the unfeeling man in the white
house
they called them hoovervilles
the final year of hoover's presidency
was marked by pr catastrophe so
incendiary they
did for his reputation what the
hindenburg did for airship travel the
year actually got off to a good start
with hoover signing the emergency relief
construction act which put aside two
billion dollars for public works but any
good that bill did was swiftly swamped
by two utterly
tone deaf moments the first was when
hoover suddenly decided to implement a
national sales tax the thinking behind
this sort of makes sense
if you squint a little hoover wanted to
raise taxes to keep the deficit down but
he didn't want to overburden the rich
who he saw
as wealth creators but well the optics
of that
are really bad no longer did hoover look
out a touch he now looked like a man
snatching the last pennies
out of starving americans pockets the
outcry was so bad that uber backed down
but not before the damage had been done
however it was the second pr blunder
that would end his humanitarian
reputation once and for all
in the summer of 1932 a large gang of
out-of-work world war one veterans
descended on washington dc they had
bonus payments due in 1945 and were
agitating to get them paid now
like when they actually needed the cash
not in 13 years time when they
all might be dead of starvation known as
the bonus army they were a nightmare for
the white house
especially when some of them started
occupying empty federal buildings so
whoever asked general douglas macarthur
to evict them macarthur responded by
unleashing hell
macarthur's soldiers attacked the bonus
army with tear gas and guns
their tents were burned tanks were
rolled in one destitute veteran was
killed
these were men who'd risked their lives
for the united states
now here they were being driven like
rats from the capital
simply for daring to demand better no
matter that macarthur had resorted to
violence on his own initiative
no matter that hoover privately deplored
the rampage
in the minds of americans hoover was now
indelibly linked with images of state
brutality
this little point going into the details
of hoover's campaign for re-election
nobody thought he was going to win a
second term
the real action was happening in the
democratic party where franklin d
roosevelt was promising a new deal to
help get the nation back on track
by the time november rolled around
voting for hoover was about as
appetizing as
drinking a bowl of dog vomit in the end
only six states went republican
in the popular vote hoover didn't even
break 40 percent worse than
even jimmy carter in 1980. still with
new presidents at that time inaugurated
in march that left hoover
five months left in office five months
in which he tried to coordinate a crisis
response with fdr
only to be rebuffed for the rest of his
life a bitter hoover would be convinced
fdr
deliberately let him flounder to tank
his reputation not that anyone needed
convincing that hoover was a bad
president when herbertover left office
on march 4
1933 his name was toxic shorthand for
shantytowns breadlines crushing poverty
and
backbreaking despair although he'd live
another 31 years dying on october
20th 1964 america never forgave him to
this day hoover ranks in surveys of
historians as
among the worst u.s presidents maybe not
quite up to warren harding's turdiness
but
a far cry from his successor yet only to
focus on hoover's disastrous single term
would be to miss the broader picture of
his life
he was a man who worked himself up from
poverty from an orphaned upbringing to
being one of the most successful
businessmen of his day
that done he didn't just sit on his ass
and count his dough but he used his
money
his connections and his superhuman
organizational skills
to literally save millions of lives in
private too
he was humble from the moment he became
secretary of commerce hoover gave his
salary away to charity a practice he
kept up all through his presidency he
was in other words
a great man had he died in 1928 he'd now
be remembered as
one of america's great philanthropists
rather than
one of its greatest disappointments
maybe it says something about the way we
remember our leaders that hoover's
inspiring first decades
are now forgotten maybe it suggests we
need a
whole new way of ranking presidents one
with a separate section for those who
like jimmy carter decades later were
crappy presidents but
also great men because make no mistake
hoover
was both those things if researching
this video has taught us anything is
that hoover deserves to be remembered
not as
herbert hoover failed president but also
herbert hoover
the man who saved millions so i really
hope you found this video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below don't forget to subscribe
thank you for watching